The internet may be replete with cats making silly faces,
but when it comes to shelter cats being adopted,
those faces might not help their chances.
In 2013, researchers found that humans
were more likely to adopt shelter dogs
that frequently raised their brows,
possibly because it makes their faces
look more puppy-like and friendly.
That led them to wonder whether potential cat adopters
pay attention to the cats’ facial expressions.
To figure this out, researchers created CatFACS.
They meticulously cataloged
every muscle contraction a cat’s face can make.
And identified 15 different facial movements,
The researchers videotaped cats at 3 shelters
to see how they responded to an approaching human
They recorded facial expressions and body movements
from 106 cats in all.
And then followed how long it took
each cat to be adopted.
Surprisingly, the cats’ facial expressions
didn’t seem to affect how quickly they were adopted
What did make a difference?
Rubbing.
Cats who rubbed their heads and bodies
on toys and objects
were adopted 30% more quickly than others
The scientists think that because dogs
were domesticated much earlier than cats,
and lived in closer quarters with people,
their facial expressions had more time
and were under more evolutionary pressure
to become friendlier to us
Whereas in cats,
we seem to rely more on overt signals
like nuzzling
to decide whether they’d make good buddies